welcome to the future of Life Institute
podcast my name is Gus docker on this
episode I talk with Anders Sandberg from
the future of humanity Institute at
Oxford University
we start out by talking about chat GPT
which is the newest language model from
openai but we also talk about in general
what we can learn from how AI has
developed about the future risks and
benefits of AI I really enjoyed this
conversation and I think you will too
here's Ander Sandberg
Andrews welcome to the podcast thank you
for being here well thank you so much
for having me
all right I assume you've been playing
around with the chat GPT
um the new language model from openai we
tried it of course I have it it's a very
fun very shiny toy right now
what what have surprised you about its
capabilities
I was probably most blown away when I
read that you could actually use it as a
fake Linux terminal to make it pretend
that it's actually a computer and you
can move around in different directories
install software surf the web except of
course it's not the real web it's a kind
of a dream web but it's imagining and I
saw people tweeting about it so I tried
it myself and I got curious what other
files I'm finding on this computer so I
found this uh folder containing uh
letters so I found the CV of the owner
of account so I read the John dose and
the the CV where he's talking about his
skills as a programmer at XYZ
Corporation
it was a weird feeling because in some
such GPT is making up a very plausible
file to find on a generic computer from
indeed a very generic person
at the same time I felt like maybe I
shouldn't go and look at the private
files because we're probably private
where is this information coming from
maybe we could explain how GPT line
models work
so generally the large language models
are glorified versions of the text
completion we have in our smartphones
you basically try to predict what is the
next word or even the next letter coming
from a previous sequence of characters
and it's apparently obvious that you can
do this in a simple statistical method
but you just take a lot of text
calculate the probability of a next word
based on the previous ones except that
that doesn't do much for grammar and
indeed this kind of random Markov chain
models have been fun sources of nonsense
poetry and since the 1970s in computer
circles what the language models do is
they add a more complex artificial
neural network that actually is aware in
some sense of previous words that have
been in a sentence if I start talking
about animals in a sentence then various
words that might be ambiguous might be
more or less likely given that the
context is animals if I switch to the
context start talking programming then
suddenly other words become more likely
this is all there is to it it's
basically predicting a sequence of
tokens
based on a large Corpus of text that you
train it on and now it just predicts the
next token and then you can of course
add more to that and it generates a
fairly likely text
this is in itself really amazing because
some of these texts actually do seem to
contain real meaning and then when you
do it interactively like in chat GPT
you're writing something and you're
getting a plausible response and it's
very hard to shake that feeling but
there is intelligence here I give an
instruction and the text responds with
following that instruction even though
what's actually going on is not so much
but there is a being that understands
that others want me to do these things
but rather it's a text that is being
updated by two actors and the game is
very much like if there is an
instruction earlier in this sequence
then that should be applied later on so
there is no real understanding in one
sense in another sense it's very clear
that I can ask these systems which
colors are more similar to each other
and I get reasonable responses
this is weird because of course these
systems have never seen an effect they
have only ever expensed a lot of text
but that text comes from humans but
generate of course a lot of color and
appreciation a lot of color names a lot
of color comparisons and given that it's
more sensible to say that green is
closer to the maybe a turquoise than
read this
then the text system will do this too
the problem is this kind of reflected
intelligence it confuses us very very
easily
yeah I think it's important to remind
ourselves how these models actually work
sometimes it's
it's
confusing to say I I had a chat with a
GPT uh the in the weekend and I had a
discussion on moral philosophy with this
model and it felt real to me it felt as
if the Marvel understood what I was
saying and then I I I asked it to
correct the point that it made because
it was wrong and it acknowledged that it
had made a wrong point but then it
repeated the point over and over again
which breaks the illusion so it it's
also amazing to think that how broad the
knowledge in these models is so I know
something about moral philosophy but you
could also ask it about asking about
engineering Bridges or art or poetry
whatever it is so in one sense as you
say
these this line of models show
understanding but in another sense it's
it's brittle understanding
it's also not sensitive to
inconsistencies which I think is very
interesting I I saw somebody that had
had a wonderful argument with chat GPT
about whether it could speak Danish and
the model was responding in Danish
saying no I don't understand Danish I'm
trained trained on an English Corpus it
was obviously wrong obviously
inconsistent and it didn't care because
that was the most likely way that where
the conversation could continue
it's interesting to think about these
abilities that to us seem uh like a
qualitative leap but they arise out of
basically the same type of model that
just has more data or has more
parameters or has longer training times
more expensive training runs but to us
it seems as if the models are learning
new things yeah for example that that's
we can now hold longer conversations
yeah what do you think this trend will
continue and we will continually be
surprised
I think it's a very good bet that we
will be surprised because our ability to
predict the capabilities of AI systems
has been demonstrated again and again to
be really bad it goes both ways people
have both been too bullish about how
easy it would be to actually program
many tasks and discovered the hard way
that computer vision is a really deep
problem but solving some problems that
are easy for young kids is actually very
hard for robots to do well it's not
terribly hard to write software but does
symbolic math that is very much more
powerful than any human could ever be so
that's more of EX Paradox that the
five-year-old is kind of outperforming
the best robot uh while the rather
simpler programs are outperforming the
professor but at the same time we're
also being wrong about things not being
doable
so in the current year of large language
model there is a lot of people who know
a lot about the language and AI that
have been making very confident
predictions about their failures and
shortcomings and that this cannot be
dealt with and usually the story is a
few months later a new version shows up
and it totally blows those problems out
of water and then typically the human
expert gives another interview where he
proclaims some other problems being
really a good test to show that this is
not true intelligence and that it cannot
possibly be solved and my bet would be
that six months later a new version
arrives and thus even that even though
the underlying basic point but yes the
language models don't really have
understanding in our sense is valid it's
worth recognizing that yes we're not
intelligent in the sense we use about
having a goal having
plans to implement physical the language
modes are just predicting strings of
tokens but we're doing it so well but
even people in robotics have started to
use them for internal communication and
planning because you can of course use
these strings of tokens and to also make
up good plan how do I make a cup of tea
have the language model describe the
steps send that to another language mode
that controls the robotic arm
so then you combine the instructions
from the instructions from a language
model with some computer vision and then
you have the beginnings of a robot that
can actually navigate in the world
yeah
so if we look back if we think say 10 or
20 years ago we perhaps would have
thought that we would have a pretty
pretty high functioning self-driving
cars by now
but that didn't turn out to be the case
at least not yet but we didn't predict
or at least I hadn't seen predictions of
language models with this kind of
capability uh as we're seeing now
can we use this information to predict
how we will be uh surprised in the
future or is that too much to expect
I I think we can use it as some kind of
analogy so generally history doesn't
repeat itself but it Rhymes so the
autonomous cores were a beautiful
example where he got the kind of
transition back in 2006 when DARPA did
its first Grand Challenge
the chorus we're not doing very well I
think none of the cars actually managed
to get the goal post even though they're
driving in an open desert
and most people were laughing and saying
yeah that's uh how bad it is
people who really paid attention said oh
this is actually getting somewhere next
year they actually all went uh and they
reached the goal post and progress
seemed to be very fast and indeed
shortly they were driving in urban
traffic
so that led us to believe that oh we're
going to get autonomous cars very soon
now
then it turned out that there was
another problem yes of course you can
make a car that drives relatively well
in a city or at least on a highway
dealing with unexpected circumstances
and making it safe enough that we can
entrust it to drive our children
that is a very different thing so right
now people are a bit more pessimistic
about the autonomous cars because
they're good enough to demonstrate that
they can be unsafe and actually getting
that extra level of safety so we would
say this is perfect to use is very very
hard
meanwhile the language models were kind
of flying under radar because most of us
didn't even think it was very important
I said they were glorified the cell
phone tax predictors
and in one sense that's exactly what
they uh or except that were so good at
predicting these sequences but you
actually can use them to solve problems
um gpt2 could with some effort to play
chess since there is enough chess games
in chess notation you still need to do a
bit of extra work to just get legal
moves I bet you can do much better with
chat GPT this is not because it's doing
a proper chess evaluation yes but the
database contains so much and generally
the big surprise to somebody like me who
learned about neural networks in the
1990s before they really worked well
before they were cool before you got a
six-figure salary for knowing this is
but the internal structure is not
fundamentally dissimilar from what we
were tooling around with it's just that
you have much bigger data sets and much
bigger compute to actually do the
training so many of the things I
solemnly told my students about black
human night is like oh yes you need to
avoid having two many degrees of freedom
in the network because you will get over
training and that's going to be very bad
turns out to be not really true these
days instead you want to have a lot of
parameters you want to have billions of
parameters because you're both training
on a much bigger data set but where even
this surprising properties where over
parameterized neural networks seem to be
broken that is actually the term that
people are using in the field now that
we find the underlying to the pattern of
a domain and then can be a very good
accurate predictions so grok is from
high lines science fiction Noble the
Moon is a harsh mystery so and a boy
reared by martians has this weird
Martian word for truly understand
something to actually be that thing and
it seems like in some situations the
underlying complexities of reality deep
down have certain patterns that you can
learn once you get enough data this was
not something we could predict but
neural networks would be good at and
indeed in the 90s my advisor told me
about the yeah deep neural networks
they're kind of a dead them the way
didn't get much more results than
original tests in the 80s and that was
totally true with the 1990s and they
stopped being it through in 2010s
because we had enough data enough
compute to run big Networks now this
story about a mixed bag of predictions
seems to suggest but over the next
decade we shouldn't be too surprised if
it turns out that there's some new
applications or architectures that
become very powerful and they might come
from almost any practical application
also that all the methods can be used
for other things so for example the
convolutional Deep neural networks that
were used in computer vision
you can do one-dimensional versions of
them to make sound syntheses and
language synthesis so we can totally
expect that as a spin-off of a working
computer vision we're going to get much
better voices and probably artificial
music that's a likely prediction
but which jobs are going to get
disrupted
Flipper die flip a coin you don't really
know uh when the Michael uh the Osborne
called Frey did their famous study on
the vote the metability of jobs that was
published in 2016 and they claimed that
47 of all jobs could be automated in the
foreseeable future
they gave probability for different jobs
and it turns out that artists and
illustrators verse only four percent
chance that it could be any automation
but of course the 2022 saw this rise of
AI art where Dali 2 and a mid-journey
and stable diffusion really scared of
our community because it's pretty clear
that at least some of Illustrator jobs
are totally getting automated meanwhile
the Insurance Underwriters that we gave
a 99 probability of they could be
automated or doing fine why well
actually their job is much more about
business relationships than actually
taking numbers filling them into
spreadsheets and calculating a premium
so it turns out that our ability to
reliably predict the consequence is raw
below and that leads to a strategy it's
kind of recognized that yeah we are
going to get surprised here and that in
itself might mean that we need to hedge
our bets quite a lot
do you think the failure rate of
language models will hold them back from
it from from being a from being used in
the world to solve actual problems like
we mentioned with the self-driving car
there the failure rate is too high for
them to actually drive our kids around
you could imagine a language model
lawyer but if that lawyer as a language
model
um every 100 Clause it produces this
complete nonsense then we can't really
trust it in a way that we perhaps can
trust humans so do you could you could
there be similar problems where language
models will confabulate or hallucinate
uh on say on true things and therefore
they they can't be used as productively
as we wish they could
yeah I think it's very likely in many
domains so the automated lawyer it's not
a problem if every 100 paragraph is
gibberish because real lawyers can also
occasionally say gibberish and it
doesn't matter
if it's a if a lawyer says something
about this aren't true on the upper hand
uh oh now they are in real trouble
and the problem is of course language
models are true bullshitters in
frankfurt's uh the the philosophical
sense they don't care about being true
or false they just generate an output
so this makes them very unsuited as they
currently are for that kind of job I I
tried out to chat GPT on chemistry
experience I asked it what happens if I
mix the following chemicals and besides
a short lecture that I shouldn't be
doing that because it's unsafe which was
totally correct it gave a somewhat
correct answer for two chemicals and
then I changed it to another chemical
and again I got a short lecture but
that's an even more unsafe experiment
which was correct and then they gave a
totally erroneous answer and it was
really convinced about this erroneous
chemistry that would not be very useful
if I actually wanted to do proper
chemistry you need to tie it the output
the actual facts in the world much more
strongly but on the other hand I tried
it to come up with scenarios for
role-playing games I pointed out that
well classic Dungeons and Dragons is in
a fantasy setting but maybe we could do
other historical settings so that first
I had it come up with good names for
spells in a classical Greek setting and
then I asked it could you come up with
some other interesting historical
settings and it suggests that the 1815
France the post-napolionic era and we're
discussing the possibilities of having
under the emperor loyalist soldiers this
was creative work it was not super
creative it was not coming up with
something that was totally unthinkably
weird but at the same time it was useful
I could tell it let's add a complication
let's add the Marshall of France
currently the king of Sweden to the
storyline and that worked out quite well
this is creative work there is no right
and wrong it's only entertaining and
less entertaining and this is where I
think it can be very powerful
if I were to use one of these models as
my personal computer as personal
assistant I really need to know that it
does what I tell it to do it needs to
actually demonstrate that it sent off
that emails and doesn't just hallucinate
but of course a set of the email sir you
actually want to be able to check that
is reliable enough but different domains
have different kinds of reliability I
can totally see people using this to
generate the large amount of text where
we don't care too much about reliability
a lot of the copy a lot of report
bureaucratic reports which are probably
going to be read by another language
model distilling it down to a shorter
forms of the rest of bureaucrat will be
certain that I have done the right thing
for the grant I got and it might be that
now we're just using these models to
send the enormous amount of verbiage but
no human ever reads
but maybe if that saves our human nerves
a nice uh that might be a good idea
it is weird that these language models
will output text that is completely
false with the same confidence or as as
they will output through the true
information so as a user if you're if we
imagine a user using this as a kind of
search engine to try to find true
information well then you have to be a
good judge of whether the AI is
bullshitting or whether it is
regurgitating true facts that it has
learned online and that I can see that
holding the models back because we in a
sense the models can be trusted to tell
the truth
well the reason is of course what are
they trained on they're trained on Reams
and reams of human text and discussion
and conversation and humans are not
super reliable even the scientific
literature is full of falsifications
errors and misunderstandings so the
reason unexperienced scientist is
somewhat reliable at their job is that
they have built an internal model that
is fairly consistent and is quite often
tested against reality
the problem with the text models is of
course they don't really care and they
don't currently have a method to test
against this
so we need to add more things to make
them really useful so I would expect the
current crop of text mods are going to
be just generating text where truth is
not the most important part the Next
Generation that might be powerful is of
course the ones that link to extra
semantic information about the world
where they actually check the
mathematics if we make equations and
make sure that it's a correct
calculation
now automated fact checking would be
really powerful imagine if you had an
assistant but constantly pointed out
when you read something whether it
actually is at variance with known facts
or not that could be very powerful
although a lot of people would
absolutely not want to hear that because
a lot of known facts they believe they
know are not true indeed it turns out
that quite a lot of facts that even
experts believe are not true there is
actually a disturbing uncertainty about
many of the things we as a civilization
believe so you it's by no means given
that even these fact Checkers are going
to bind the actual truth sometimes we
might even act against it because well
the official view on what the state of
the world is might actually be incorrect
but only in the right way I think this
can be very very powerful
the real problem is of course A lot of
people are just going to use it naively
or recognize that it's unreliable but
it's uh the the five to five o'clock and
they want to get home and they need to
write 10 pages of text let's have a
language more generated let's skim over
it and yeah it looks good enough and
let's send it off
so we might very well end up in a world
with a lot of unreliable verbiage which
we already live in of course but now we
get much more of it the funniest part is
of course but you also get a lot of
weird lies from these models because
they are trained on what humans output
and if you ask a human are you a robot
most people will argue no I'm not a
robot and will give various arguments
that is of course part of a training
data there is a lot of examples online
of that so of course the language models
tend to respond unless you specifically
train them not to respond like that by
pretending to be human this can
sometimes be very amusing and sometimes
downright creepy we have a lot of his
accidental lies because we have a system
that's not a human trained on data
generated by humans and before long
we're going to have very different kinds
of systems and entities that might
actually be needed to train or to
recognize what kind of entity they are
what claims we can and cannot make this
is complicated and it's an interesting
issue because it's not just programming
it's prompt engineering and to some
extent even the sociology of
understanding what is this system for
imagine if these language models begin
generating a lot of text because it's
simply it's so easy for them to generate
a lot of text at the request of of a lot
of humans and then further imagine that
this text is uploaded online and
included in the training set of the next
language model then you could you could
see how the ball could get rolling on a
very weird
um hallucinatory model where the the AI
is learning by data that previous AI
models have created and so maybe maybe a
a new field is hunting for authentic
human text
oh yeah uh I think this might actually
be quite important there is already some
work by the people developing image
generation models that they should have
watermarks so they can recognize that
they should not be part of a training
data there are some natural governments
that have started to say that yeah you
need to start adding watermarks uh to
what is being generated and part of that
is of course not polluting the well
because one scenario I envisioned is a
spamocalypse for example today if you
want to get a recipe online it's very
likely that the top recipe you get will
have a preamble about five screen pages
about a lovely holiday in Sicily and
those lovely lemons before you get to
the lemon meringue recipe at the bottom
why well of course it's being monetized
there is uh those impressions as you
scroll past the ads at the side that
actually make them a site pay for itself
now writing that the verbiage about the
holiday that nobody should really read
that much that could be done by a
language model
but also recipes can can't be
copyrighted they're not creative texts
they're a list of ingredients so
actually you can totally steal that from
another site but you will probably want
to rewrite it a little bit so we don't
harass you too much and I can totally
foresee that of course an unscrew the
scrupulous web designer would say yeah
I'm going to use language mod to make
recipes and preambles and then I get to
add clicks and then I'm making money and
then of course the next day and they are
going to be doing this for something
else than recipes so the internet might
get filled with this auto-generated
context
pretending to be human and also of
course becoming part of training data
which might mean that now the language
modes are getting very confused about
what ingredients actually are in apple
pie
because if you get random noise in there
at some point maybe carrots should be
part of apple pie the model doesn't know
it just includes it
so you could get an erosion of our
shared epistemic system here if this is
not handled well so obviously you want
something that checks the fact against
reality and you might also want a flag
that this was probably auto-generated
but we might also want to think about
the whole systems we have about recipes
or scientific papers these epistemic
systems are kind of fragile and the
incentives for maintaining them well are
not always well aligned
I don't know if you grade undergraduate
essays at Oxford but uh does this
support you that that you will you will
have essays handed in that have been
drafted by a language model or perhaps
you know handed in directly from a
language model do you think this is an
actual threat or are they not Advanced
enough to to fake and Oxford
undergraduate yet
I think they're not good enough to fake
an Oxford undergraduate he said with
some pride but uh that is right now and
I fully expect that I'm going to see
some of these essays before in fact it
would be a good thing if the philosophy
faculty sprinkled in a few
auto-generated essays just to check that
the faculty is actually alert enough
if the problem I think with
auto-generated philosophy is is that
we're based on what is in the big Corpus
what everybody knows or at least what
somebody has argued so it's not going to
break new ground normally you don't
expect undergraded essays to do that and
that is the big problem so once you get
up on the Master's level and PhD level
you might actually want to demand that
this should be unique stuff but nobody
has actually started before and that
might be possible to even check for but
if you just have somebody explain what
how Epicurean ideas affected the
Machiavelli
yeah I think the language mods are going
to do a decent job on this so at that
point the obvious solution we need to do
a proper philosophy tutorial where I sit
across from a student Oscar so can you
explain what the epicurus and
Machiavelli ever had to do with each
other
that might be the only way and it might
very well be that the student says yeah
but shouldn't I be allowed to use a
language model to partner partly make my
arguments after all over in engineering
we're allowed to use pocket calculators
and I think there is some Merit too it
might be that the right kind of models
might actually improve things I would
love to have an argument validity
detector for my own text but reads the
text and checks does this make poor
model sense and actually warned me when
I'm kind of deducing too much hand
waving and that might be useful that
would be a tool just like a pocket
calculator that we should want to have
but the earliest application or of
course going to be cheating I have no
doubt whatsoever that a lot of very bad
scientific papers are being generated
right at this moment are being sent to a
lot of journals for review by people who
really want to pad their CV
and we need to deal with that we need to
find better ways of actually checking
the papers are useful but they are true
but we have validity that experiments
were actually done
um and that's going to be tough going
this reminds me of this mirrors a debate
about you know you have a say a third
grade student learning how to add or
subtract how to do basic math and and
then this the discussion is around well
I will always have a calculator and
they're right they will always have a
calculator in their pocket uh we will
always I'm guessing have these language
models available and they will only get
better so why should we artificially
handicap our own Thinking by not using
them and perhaps the answer there is
that well we are training human ability
so we are we're training critical
thinking or ability to to do math
mentally and so on and and if if we oh
if we Outsource our learning to these
tools well then we will never gain the
human abilities
that could be one answer of course the
skeptic might say yeah but why do I want
to have that ability and my answer to
the math student would be it's actually
very useful to check in to check the
sanity of your answer if you can do a
quick math in your head quite often that
is an extra Safeguard that's very useful
to the philosophy student you might say
yeah but don't you actually love wisdom
don't you actually want to figure out
for yourself what is true
after all you're not going to become
rich by your spouting off about
Machiavelli and Benton you actually need
to have some proper understanding
because the language models are dealing
with the surface level of a message very
a very good model of what uh other a
text would be like but that text is
supposedly reflecting some underlying
understandings and Concepts now it seems
like the language modes are good enough
that they almost imitate this deeper
level well enough and indeed quite a lot
of our languages we use every day is
probably not smarter at all than the
language model we're just generating
words but fit with this situation and
where I bump into a chair and I
apologize to it but not because I'm
thinking that the chair is an individual
but I need to apologize to it's just a
reflex because well I bump into somebody
and something and then they see
responsive to apologize
but getting that deeper level that
semantic information those meanings that
is tricky and we might actually want to
have systems that tie more closely into
that especially when you want to have
True full language models gpt3 you could
actually improve it through fullness by
asking it to give a truthful answer
because you need to point out that we're
interested in the part of language that
deals with true statements rather than
the big part of language that's
arbitrary ones but you might also want
to hardwiring things but it actually
checks the numbers it's giving against
known data in the world that would be
working on a deeper semantic level of
course we might also train on a lot of
things and hope that maybe these models
will grock the deeper semantics of the
world in which case we're actually
approaching some better understanding of
the real thing but in many cases there
were many deeper levels we might be
having a conversation about one topic
but actually the real reason we're doing
a conversation might be a political game
in our organization or something very
different actually understanding what's
really going on can have quite a lot of
levels some of which are unsaid some of
which might even be unknown to the
participants they don't really know why
we're engaging in some kind of social
game but there are reasons for that we
really want to have a model that might
be able to act on those levels and the
deeper they get of course the closer we
get to real intelligence
but I think the language models are
going to be a bit like the pocket
calculator very good for making texts
look good I make a sketch of what my
argument is and then they fill out the
details and make a nice rhetorical
flourish I'm proud to admit that I
actually did this a few months ago with
the paper I couldn't come up with a good
in the end point of a paper uh it was a
simple one about plastic recycling
nothing fancy but I couldn't come up
with a good rhetorical flourish so I had
GPT free give me a few Alternatives I
choose one and added that for the first
iteration of a paper
it didn't contain enough science it was
no research it was just a nice send-off
of this is why we think this is a useful
method and it's going to help solve the
waste problem but expressed in a nice
way but you might want to have a deeper
levels too you want that fact check here
you want the math to check here you want
to have maybe a system pointing out to
you by the way this argument you're
giving is very related to that book you
read last week maybe a very solid
correlation here
do you think that there's anything deep
to this notion of understanding or will
it kind of dissipate when we find out
that
the future language models can can in
fact simulate what we would deem to be a
deep understanding of a topic do you
think do you think that do you think
when you say uh when you talk about
whether a language model understands
something do you think we mean the same
thing by understanding
yeah I don't think normal human
understanding and language model I
understand they are the same thing they
work in slightly different ways so when
I say that I understand let's say some
equations in astrophysics that typically
means that I can use them I can use them
to calculate things I can explain what
happens if you change the equations a
bit I might know something about the the
range of parameters where they're valid
and so on I might be able to tell you I
found this story about how they were
discovered
now this is not just making a simple
prediction about the output language
models are very good at making these
predictions of output but they generally
don't have that causal connectedness
generally what the current machine
learning is weak at is understanding the
causal effect I do something something
happens they're thinking all in terms of
correlation and this quite often works
well as they say a correlation does not
imply a causation but as some weight
added but it certainly winks
suggestively the if things are
correlated with each other they usually
have something to do with each other
quite a lot of stupid errors happen when
you assume one causes valver quite often
there is something hidden beneath or
behind that of course both to happen
together if you can discern that then
you have understood the situation and
can do much more interesting things like
changing that underlying factor in the
useful ways this is something I think
language models right now are unlikely
to be good at but again their General
sequence prediction tools it might be a
very risky to say they can never ever do
this it might very well turn out that
with the right kind of training or the
right kind of applications they can
actually start finding correlation
structures
I think Judea Pearl and many others
would say no way we're not buying that
then give very very clever Arguments for
why this cannot happen and it wouldn't
surprise me but it might generally not
but I but there might be domains where
it actually works well enough but you
can get in a cheap causation
understanding and that's good enough for
those domains but it might also be that
we have a very important domains where
this absolutely doesn't work and you
think a totally misled we need to learn
those the difference the different
domains and the boundaries between them
do you think that language models
abilities to generate lists of of
actions so for example give me a list of
the things I need to do the actions I
need to take to get a cup of coffee well
okay get the cup boil the water put the
coffee in is that a very rudimentary uh
understanding of causality I don't think
it's a understandable causality it's an
understanding that humans explaining how
to make coffee and tea make it in this
order humans generally I assume have an
understanding of causality when we're in
the kitchen and then they recount on how
they did it and then they don't explain
how they concluded but you need to pour
in the water after bringing the cup it's
just always there so then you get a
correlation structure that the system
learns and now it looks like it has a
causative understanding and it's even
General enough that if you say I don't
have a teacup in my kitchen can I use a
glass it will probably say yeah you can
use a glass bring the glass pour in the
water
you do get something that is very
similar but it's a bit deceptive because
it's actually not based on understanding
the causative structure now a lot of our
language is full of assumptions about
causality so many that I think it looks
down what the language model can say in
such a way that it actually borrows our
sense of in the causation and I think
this is generally what happens with the
language models there is so much human
output but you can actually borrow all
of this and use that reflected
Brilliance to look like you actually
understand the things you can steal
human common sense and give it back to
us so that it looks like you have common
sense in air exactly yeah yeah yeah of
course how many of us also look very
intelligent actually we just read a lot
of stuff and listen to podcasts but
actually uh in a conversation we bring
up some nice Bon Martin uh so cool fact
and it sounds like we are very very wise
but actually yeah it's the rest of
mankind channeled through us
I think that's a very common experience
we should talk so you've hinted at this
or talked about it but we should we
should think about how these models will
evolve how they'll get more grounded how
they'll gain semantic understanding
perhaps how they will become multimodal
so will they incorporate
images or
um video and so on it could what what's
future directions could these models go
in
so the real issue is not so much what
you want to add but just how much can
you add and do you have enough compute
for it so making a multimodal language
model seems totally obvious just add a
camera and a microphone and now you get
a data stream which in many ways is
similar to just getting the text Data
stream
there are some issues about noise about
training but basically we're talking
about patterns of data and finding an
architecture that's good at handling it
probably you might say yeah I'm going to
put in some model like open a as whisper
uh to actually parse the language
because we already worked rather hard on
that so instead of just having
unfiltered sound my multimodal image is
going to look for the camera and hear
what people are saying although having
the raw Sound Stream might also be
useful because the chirping of birds and
the the Bowing of dogs actually is also
part of that world and then presumably
it would do a good sequence prediction
and be able to predict in a scene what's
supposed to happen next
but the problem here is more like okay
can you get enough training data so
right now we have been using that idea
that we can get enormous amount of
training data get it suitably labeled
and then produce a nice output the
problem is of course getting cheap label
training data is tricky I think we run
out of that thing people used to say
that data is the new oil and right now I
think we're approaching a kind of weird
oil crisis having a really good curated
repository of good training data is not
trivial to get your hands on would this
data have to be human labeled or could
we have ai labeled training data for AI
with some quality control mixed in could
we could be set up this training set so
that it wouldn't pollute the model and
degrade performance but would instead
perhaps expand performance improve
performance I would bet that you could
do interesting things here because you
could start by having a model trying to
label the data a human responding and
the expensive and rare human
interventions come and train an internal
critic that helps retrain the actual
labeling model
um this is something that has been
discussed a fair bit in the AI safety
and the AI Alignment World because there
ideally you would want the robots and
the AI systems to always do what humans
want them to do or make sense but humans
are so slow and it's so expensive to ask
humans for advice so instead what you do
is you try to train on a human giving a
bit of scarce advice
so you get an internal model pretending
to be that human giving advice of the
same style and then try to see can this
trade well and it seems to work
surprisingly well I don't know whether
this could work in these applications
but it's certainly worth trying and I
would be very surprised to hear that
nobody is doing it right now
how have your opinions about AI safety
changed because of how AI AIS have
actually turned out so perhaps in the
90s we didn't have that many examples of
actual AIS and perhaps now we do I don't
know if that's an actual uh of if that's
an accurate picture but that's that's
kind of my summary of the history here
now we have some examples of simple AIS
uh have you understand how have your
opinions changed about how we can make
these models safe
so back in the 90s very few if any
people were really thinking about AI
safety it's well worth noticing but
people in the 1950s were claiming that
oh within a generation we're going to
get human level Ai and we're not
concerned about safety at all there's
this very famous research proposal where
they this is in I think 1956 and they
proposed that with a give a small group
of researchers at summer and they will
make significant progress in artificial
intelligence research that's that's the
start of the field where with a very
overconfident prediction but go ahead oh
yeah the dwarf move conference that this
was about was also accurate they did
actually do a surprising amount of
useful stuff over summer because there
was nothing before when there is nothing
any Improvement is infinite Improvement
but they were very optimistic about
getting powerful Ai and even some people
like Alan Turing and IJ good were aware
that well once again at self-improving
AI that's going to be very dramatic but
none of them really seriously talked
about the safety issues and part of it
might be that they still had that
distrust because when you see how badly
your actual system work well you have a
hard time believing that it could be
powerful enough to matter and very it's
a lot of cheap talk
in the 90s I was part of a transhumanist
movement we were all very bullish about
the imminent technological singularity
and this is going to be great and we had
members of the mailing lists argue that
we need to speed up the singularity so
we should really be working hard to make
an artificial intellencies that could
act as a seed AGI to improve itself and
it's actually from those conversations
we got a lot of early safety thinking
because some of the people involved sort
of realizing wait a minute if we're
taking this absolutely seriously I
believe that we could get this
exponential growth of something becoming
smarter and smarter that means that we
are essentially creating a good and its
values are going to be set by whatever
we happen to program and at this point
any programmer realize oh I mess up all
the time and oh if I mess up programming
something good like that's scary
that led to a conversation about how do
you actually make something that is safe
and from some of these discussions you
actually end up in the earliest part of
the AI safety debate but it's worth
noting this was not part of the
mainstream this was among the weirdo
futurists meanwhile the AI resources in
the 90s they were mostly interested in
making sure that the industrial robots
don't squish people that had been a
concern since the 1970s and it's a valid
relevant concern but AI being used for
any super important jobs in the world
they knew the field well enough to think
that this is not very likely to be a
problem right now we can wait
and I was probably very much in that
world even though I was one of those
optimistic futurists AI seemed fairly
far away I was much more optimistic
about many other Technologies
and again it turns out that futurists
are very bad at predicting which
technology arrive early so while life
extension is going on nicely but a bit
too slowly for my taste uh nano
technology got misdirected by the
sociology of research funding while
biotechnology is charging on but so
unpredictable we can't tell anything new
space is way ahead of what we would have
expected while AI for a long time didn't
do anything and then suddenly just
jumped and became much more of an urgent
issue and that made me concerned about
AI safety I've always been much more
optimistic than many of my friends in
this field uh perhaps just because of
Personality rather than facts and good
reasoning but it seems to me that yeah
we're getting systems that can amplify
you my performance tremendously that's
already enough to be a course of serious
concern it also looks like we are bad at
predicting when the performance can
increase and even what they're doing
once they have a higher performance
these are very good reasons to work very
hard on designing them better finding
better ways of validating and testing
them and understanding the consequence
of a society the problem right now seems
to be that the field is a bit divided
between AI Ephesus that are looking at
the standard ethical issues that you get
from these systems and they're rightly
concerned about the bias in algorithms
and how power accumulates but they tend
to totally dismiss concerns about the
power of AI systems themselves and the
transformative power while the people
working on the transformative AI side uh
they or to some extent dismissing the
everyday ethical issues because they
seem to be so small compared to the
really explosive power of a powerful
system so unfortunately we have ended up
with two communities that don't talk to
each other enough and they don't get
along enough to actually be helpful
because it's pretty obvious that if you
can make an AI system but can understand
human social mores well enough not to be
racist
then that is also a helpful thing for
figuring out a system that can
understand human social mores enough to
be somewhat value aligned with humans
and that might not be an issue of just
trying to change the training date that
might require some Robert deep
architectural discussions it might also
be that we need to think a lot about
governance and long-term strategy
especially if AI is going to become very
transformative I think many of the
current discussion about the aifx are
going to be blown out of the water
simply because just too much happens
as we saw with AI art in 2022 that shock
really shocked an entire community and
let a big debate and we're going to see
this probably every year for the next 10
20 years where different groups that
never expected in their whole life but
AI would matter to them suddenly
interrupts there and it becomes
Paramount
there is this core technical issue in AI
safety of aligning an AI model to a set
of values any set of values where the
goal is just
for any set of values can we make it so
that the AI pursues these values for
example we could call it the values of
humanity as opposed to some random
values but there's also the the
philosophical side of deciding which
values we should have the the AI pursue
and you quickly get into difficult
discussions if we're thinking about now
say we have an a language model that we
have trained and
improved over time so that it does not
output racist content perhaps the same
the same techniques could be used to
have a language model that that does not
uh criticize various governments for
example and then you you start you start
to see how they could be worries about
authoritarian governments using this to
read the internet and pick out uh
what I'm saying is that we have
conflicting
um we have conflicting goals here and
some of them will will collide with each
other and we and there's they are super
difficult questions about which values
to to give to these AI
yeah we don't know what the True Values
we ought to have are if and it's an
ongoing debate I think we made some
progress over the last 2500 years but
yeah it's a complicated issue uh
similarly what kind of rules do you want
built into the AIS that is also a real
important thing it's a matter both of
power and utility uh for example many of
the image and rating systems don't make
naughty pictures and you can kind of
understand that open a I don't want to
generate that because we're a company
they don't want to mess around with the
issues of political propaganda and the
pornography so they carefully trained
daily to not to do that which had other
interesting side effects because if you
remove not the pictures from the
training data that means that you
actually remove a large number of
predominantly female people
which means that you get a gender bias
which they corrected for so in this case
we have a bit of an understanding of a
particular bias but it probably also had
other effects that we don't even notice
because we don't even understand what's
going on and you can imagine of course
making AI systems that don't uh help you
do dangerous things but what is
dangerous
and this goes back to the more deep
philosophical debate about for example
freedom of expression many outrageous
ideas have turned out to be true so it's
actually a good thing to be able to
express outrageous ideas and it might
very well be a good thing to have ai org
systems that can make in both the sexual
and political pictures indeed if you go
to a fancy art gallery or Art Museum
typically the artworks that you know the
curators and the reviewers talk the most
about are the ones that probably the AI
program would not allow to be made
so it might very well be that we want
diversity here and that actually goes
back to the interesting value alignment
problem because it seems like one very
valuable approach to this is to
recognize that we are uncertain about
this and the AI ought to be uncertain
about the two we might say we want you
to make people happy and then hopefully
the AI system recognizes that you must
don't quite on me know what they mean by
happy and uh we and make us also is a
bit uncertain and actually they might
not like my in a proposal because their
literature is full of dystopias that
pretend to be Utopias and stories about
AI progress doing bad things
um when they're giving good commands I
should be carefully so you actually want
to learn many of these things about an
axiological uncertainty we're uncertain
about the value is normative uncertainty
we're even uncertain about what morality
to do uncertainty about the world our
place in it Etc
what does this uncertainty do well it
softens thing if you're absolutely
certain as an AI program what you should
do you will just do it and that seems to
be very dangerous AI programs that are
good at handling uncertainty are
probably not going to go ahead wire
quite as strongly
now this still leaves us with another
big AI save the problem that's AI
programs doing what you must tell them
to do but you must happen to be
malicious or misguided or stupid and
there's a lot of those people out there
and if their power get Amplified we're
going to see a lot of trouble but at
least we have some ideas about the
valley alignment problem and uncertainty
but they go well together and one of the
most interesting things about language
models is that the text we see if that
is just the thing that is being
generated it's the most likely words
following each other a bit randomly but
there are many alternative ways the text
could have gone we might want to have
tools to actually see the alternative
versions of a text to be able to
backtrack and say actually let's follow
this other branch of thinking or this
other branch of style
I think we actually can develop better
tools for interacting with these systems
so it's not just a question about
training data or having bigger computers
but also getting better training data
and better tools for interactively
working with them some of the best
images I've seen generated by Machine
learning AI art
or done by having them make a few
pictures Advantage human paints over a
section says over here I want the house
or this part of a uniform should be a
bit more science fictional and that
phase make it Sterner and then you
iterate you have an interactive work now
this is where I think chat GPT is such
an interesting tool because it's not
just generating a text one time you're
actually having a conversation you're
nudge it in different directions it's
still by no means perfect it's very easy
to get it into totally inconsistent
state but that interaction is also a
good way of conveying now this direction
is the wrong path we might want to go
down another path
I agree that having AIS be uncertain
about values is an is an interesting
research Direction but I worry that it's
simply easier to to make an AI that has
a more hard-coded or precisely specified
utility function it might be easy but
it's also likely to fail in Annoying
Ways so imagine that you're running your
authoritarian government and your
program your AI to follow your official
ideology do you now get on AI but you
are aligned with probably not because
MILF authoritarian rulers actually don't
behave according to their own ideology
and this comes back again and again to
buy this indeed NSA probably felt that
Snowden was a very trustworthy
individual because it was going on about
the Constitution all the time and we're
so aligned with the Constitution and its
values which turned out that Snowden
disagreed with so similarly that the AI
with black and white utility function
might very well say my authoritarian
government is not obeying its uh
Sinister in ideology well enough I need
to make it do that which might be a bad
news for the leadership of that
government so a well-defined utility
function it quite often backfires in
interesting ways I I imagine that we're
surviving authoritarian governments
would also say yeah we want a bit more
uncertainty it should recognize that
with some nuances and subtleities in our
Sinister agenda so it shouldn't just be
treating it black and white
that's one direction to go true true
Anders uh thank you for talking with us
thank you so much
that's it for this episode on the next
episode I talk with Anders about his
upcoming book Grand Futures which is
about what Humanity could do at the very
limits of physics